you remember your first time bucko uh
no no never happened really
you've never masturbated no oh my gosh
brother
wow man what is that called is that what
do you guys call that
nothing really there's got to be a
special nickname i think in
gay culture if it's a man in gay culture
a guy that's never kissed a woman is
called a golden oreo
so i wonder what that is my god brother
damn you just have just baby's breath
inside of your
nuts right now that is damn beautiful
brother congratulations man
thank you you think you'll be able to
hold the line are you trying to hold the
line until marriage you think or just
until a relationship
yeah until marriage wow
good for you brother and do you feel
like you have more of an inner strength
going on
i do yeah
you know i had breakfast with a guy a
couple weeks ago and he'd never
masturbated and i
i was just so jealous
because the rest because i masturbated
honestly less than
probably 11 hours ago or 12 hours ago
i couldn't get to sleep and i just felt
the devil just climbing up and down my
penis and i just had to do something
when you get that feeling what do you do
just chill out put your hands on ice or
what
um i don't really get the feeling damn
now what if you get erection in your
body what do you do
can't say i get that either what really
oh my god
oh and do you think you have you might
have an iron deficiency or something or
do you think it's just
no i think i just contain it damn
you like damn chun li bruh
god god
dude how far could you jump i bet you
could jump down 11 feet huh
i wish i bet if you tried hard you could
man
unbelievable the unjackable riley mao
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for being here today brother
thanks for i didn't know that man
i did not know i was sitting here
with just a man that was riding that
paste baby all the way to the finish
line
because yeah i struggle with it man i
just
i do good and then i just struggle you
know
but i hate just jerking out i hate it
but what do you say to people out there
who
are considering it or on the fence about
masturbation
um i mean i would say do as you please
but
i wouldn't recommend it i'm one of those
few guys that wouldn't recommend it wow
and do you know other people who are
like you just like a damn human
christmas carol
i do you do wow
and y'all meet up somewhere or something
do you are you guys in a group chat
um not really a group chat but you guys
know who each other are right
damn
you know i've always it's like a super
power
it is a super everybody wants to be iron
man
you know but iron man
you know he ain't nutting out at night
he ain't
in there making macadamias in his
bedroom you know
so there is a lot of power in chin up
cheese up hoes down baby you know what
i'm saying
i do you do dang so do you ever think
about the long
road you have to hoe before you're gonna
get to some uh
you know some you know skeet that's what
they call it in the urban community
yeah it comes across my mind a few times
i almost want to be there when it
happens brother no homo you know
i'll invite you well come on now that
might be a bit
you know but maybe i'll be outside if
there's a window or something i want to
be right up front
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one